وقبل ان نتابع نشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل
كتائب القسام تقول انها استهدفت اليه
صهيونيه من نوع همر في حي الشيخ رضوان
بمدينه غزه ومقتل من فيها بعد احتراقها
بالكامل ينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام الياس كيف يتفاعل قصف
المقاومه لتل
ابيب السي يتفاعل ربما من خلال هذه القصه
القصيره اي حقيقه احد المراسلين العسكريين
الذي قضى 77 يوما من عمر هذه الحرب وهو
يتحدث عن الانتصارات العسكريه للجيش
الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه ويحرض الساسه
والعسكر ويقول لهم الويل لكم اذا اوقفت
هذه الحرب قب قبل ان تقضوا على حركه حماس
عسكريا وسياسيا وقبل ان تدمروا غزه
بالكامل لا ترحموا احدا الان قبل عندما
دوت صافرات الانذار في مدينه تلي ابيب صعد
على الهواء وسالوه اي ما الذي يجري كيف
تفسر ذلك انه بعد 74 يوما المقاومه
الفلسطينيه قادره على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ
باتجاه مدينه تل ابيب وماذا اجابهم اجابهم
لا اعرف هذا كان الجواب وهذا ربما السي ما
يفسر حاله الغضب الشديده التي تعتري حقيقه
المجتمع الاسرائيلي الذي يتساءل عن كيفيه
تمكن المقاومه الفلسطينيه بعد
74 يوما من عمر هذه الحرب على ان يضرب تل
ابيب وضرب تل ابيب ليس امرا عبثيا حقيقه
لانه رمز كبير بالنسبه لاسرائيل وهو قلبها
النابض الاقتصادي وهو المكان الذي يعيش
فيه اكبر عدد من من الاسرائيليين في داخل
اسرائيل لكن واضح بان المجتمع الاسرائيلي
يتلقى فقط انصاف
المعلومات في هذه الحرب ويتلقى هذه
المعلومات بشكل احادي الجانب من الناطق
العسكري الاسرائيلي الذي يخبره كل يوم عن
انتصارات الجيش الاسرائيلي في داخل قطاع
غزه وعن الوصول الى مستودعات السلاح وعن
تفكيك العبوات الناسفه وعن الوصول الى
الانفاق الهجوميه وما الى ذلك لكن لا
يستطيع ان يفسر له او يجيب على السؤال كيف
يمكن للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بعد 74 يوما من
عمر هذه الحرب ض مدينه تل ابيب الكبرى
وضرب ضواحيها وهو نفسه ايضا الناطق
العسكري وهو نفسه ايضا الاعلام الاسرائيلي
الذي هو جزء لا يتجزا من المؤسسه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه او الناطقه بلسان الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمؤسسه الاسرائيليه الاعلام
الاسرائيلي متطوع في خدمه هذه المؤسسه هو
يحجب نصف الحقيقه على الاقل عن المجتمع
الاسرائيلي عندما لا يقول الحقيقه حقيقه
ما يجري اولا للمدنيين من الفلسطينيين منذ
74 عاما يوما الدمار الكبير في داخل قطاع
غزه هدم المنازل قتل الاطفال قتل النساء
الجرائم التي ترتكب وما يتكبده الجيش
الاسرائيلي ايضا في المعارك الضاريه
والشرسه التي يخوضها مع المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في داخل قطاع غزه لان كل مقاطع
الفيديو التي ينشرها القسام او سرايا
القدس وغيرها من الفصائل الفلسطينيه هذه
الصور لا تصل الى المجتمع الاسرائيلي لا
تصل الى الاعلام الاسرائيلي التي يمنع ايه
الذي يمنع نشرها وبالتالي المجتمع
الاسرائيلي تصله نصف الحقيقه بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي منتصر في داخل قطاع غزه واذ
بمدينه تل ابيب الكبرى تقصف هذا اليوم
بهذا الوابل من الصواريخ وتهز اركان
المدينه اي دفعه صاروخيه ادت الى دوي
صافرات الانذار في عشرات المدن
الاسرائيليه الكبرى السي ليس فقط في مدينه
تل ابيب في ريشون لسيون في نست سيونا في
حولون هذه الضواحي الجنوبيه لمدينه تل
ابيب في الضواحي الشرقيه رمادان بن براك
وحتى وصولا الى اللد والرمله ومطار بن
جريون الدولي وعشرات البلدات الاسرائيليه
الصغيره والكبيره والمتوسطه فيما يعرف
بالسهل الداخلي وهي المناطق الواقعه الى
الشرقي من من الدود والشرقي من مدينه تلي
ابيب وبالتالي هذا الامر يفرض تساؤلات
كثيره الا الان في الاعلام الاسرائيلي
يتساءلون ما الذي يفعله الجيش الاسرائيلي
في قطاع غزه منذ 74 يوما بعد كل هذا القصف
الجوي العنيف والقصف المدفعي العنيف
والبحري وكل الاله العسكريه الكبيره
والتكنولوجيا المتطوره الجيش الاسرائيلي
الذي يوصف بانه الجيش الذي لا يقهر لا
يستطيع ان يخمد نيران هذه الصواريخ التي
تقصف تل ابيب والتي قصفت قبل ايام عديده
ايضا الجبال الغربيه لمدينه القدس وكان
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ت تعيد هذه المواجهه
الى ايامها الاولى لان من تابع في الساعه
الاخيره السي تطبيق الجبهه الداخليه
لصافرات الانذار يرى بان صافرات بان كل
المنطقه الوسطى ل لاسرائيل اصطبغت باللون
الاحمر عشرات المدن الاسرائيليه الكبرى
والصغرى والبلدات الصغيره دوت فيها صافرات
الانذار وادخلت ملايين الاسرائيليين اكثر
من ثلاثه ملايين اسرائيلي على اقل تقدير
الى الملاجئ والى الاماكن الامنه رغم ان
الجبهه الداخليه حاولت في الاسابيع
الاخيره ان تبدا باعاده هذه المدن الى
الحياه الطبيعيه الى سير الحياه الطبيعيه
في ظل حاله طوارئ بحدها الادنى لكن ان
تدوي صافرات الانذار في عز الظهر في مدينه
تلي ابيب والاعمال والاشغال في في ذروتها
والمدارس تعمل هذا امر يعني يثير تساؤلات
كثيره في المجتمع الاسرائيلي ويثير كثير
من التساؤلات ايضا في اوساط المحللين
والمراقبين العسكريين الذين ينظرون الى
هذه الحرب من صف
المراقب والمتابع لاحداثها ويقولون بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي ليس فقط لم ينجز صوره
انتصار ربما لم يحقق
انتصارا كبيرا على المقاومه التي لم ترفع
الرايه البيضاء كما يقولون هذا يقوله
محللون عسكريون و ضباط سابقون في الجيش
الاسرائيلي حركه حماس لم تستسلم بعد حركه
حماس لم ترفع الرايه البيضاء وحركه حماس
لم ترفع ايديها مستسلمه حتى هذا اليوم